الناس ما كانتش يعني مصدقه امكانيه وجود
مشروع تعتربيه اسماك في معتمديه بني خداش
يعني حاجه مستحيله على الاخر برفايه
يعرضني حده الحاجه
يعني شفتك في الفيسبوك اما مش في بالي انت
موجوده اما الحوت موش موجود يعني مشروع
يعني يكون موجود
كوثر اختصاص في الصيد البحري وتربيه
الاحياء المائيه من ولايه مدنين
[موسيقى]
صغيره بديت نسوق فيها بشوي بشوي كانت حاجه
غريبه معناه انا فيديو مش مصدقه يعني
من الاول
بالتجربه بتاعي هادي عملت ريكورد خرجت
الحوت بتاعي
بديت الناس معناها تعرف فيه بشوي بشوي مع
الميديا معناها عونتني برشا
اكثر حاجه معناها زادت عرفتني اللي هو حوت
يتربى في بني خداش اللي هي منطقه شبه
صحراويه جبليه يعني حاجه مستحيله يعني حوت
في ابن خديجه
[موسيقى]
مع قطر في الكوب دوماط طلعت
عجبتهم
المشكله فيش في المشكله كانت في الكونتين
على خاطر الكونتيتيه معنا الكميه اللي
عندي ماهيش ماهيش كبيره يعني باش نكمل
معاهم سنوك ان كانت الكميه معناها كبيره
وموجود يعني بكثره وكلكم تنجم نكمل معناها
في المشوار هذايا وان شاء الله ان شاء
الله في المستقبل يعني
ده كل دول حتى انا كنت نقول لك باش نعرف
وقتاش نجيب بالضبط يعني
[موسيقى]
واضحه اوكي عايشك عايله
[تصفيق]